[Applaudissements]
la première fois que j'ai plongé sur les
dorsales océaniques c'était au large du
mexique campagne américaine avec trois
navires et un sous-marin deux
hélicoptères tous les médias du monde
venus voir ce que nous allions trouver
sur le fond le fond c'était celui du
pacifique l'océan le plus jeune le plus
grand le plus beau
on plonge sous les tropiques mais on
s'habille comme si on allait au pôle au
bout du bateau le sous marin
on monte on ferme où nous descend à la
surface de l'eau le sous-marin s'enfonce
mollement
on descend et le pilote demande qu'est
ce que vous voulez comme musique
qu'aimez-vous comme musique on descend
l'angoissent se fait grandissante
donc dès ce en dehors c'est tout bleu à
100 m tout d'un coup
soudain la musique à tue-tête mozart
on descend
de 100 à 1000 mètres c'est tout noir
mais dehors ça scintille d'organismes
phosphorescent on descend on approche
prêt du fonds 2600 m on fait silence les
spots s'allume d'un coup et inonde de
lumière le sol jonché de formes bizarres
inconnu expérience humaine intégrale la
temporalité se courbent l'espace se
contraint l'emphase est magique
mais tout est lent infiniment lent alors
avancé campagne on savait quoi penser
des grands fonds un désert 10 et on
essaie normale sans lumière il n'y a pas
de photosynthèse photosynthèse pas de
nourriture et sans nourriture très peu
de possibilités de vie mais quand on a
vu tous ces animaux c'est prypiat rouge
dans des tubes blanc quand on a vu cet
animal hirsute sortir de la paroisse des
fumées des fumeurs sous une pluie de
sulfures métallique alors là oui on a
compris que on n'avait jamais vu ça que
c'était nouveau que c'était un monde
peuplé de bêtes extravagantes ou
gigantesques mais comment prospérer dans
cette obscurité
alors on a cherché on a cherché on a
trouvé
on a trouvé un processus alternatif à la
photosynthèse la chimiosynthèse c'est
quoi la chimiosynthèse
c'est la capacité qu'a le vivant de
transformer du minéral en organique
l'organique c'est ce que produit le
vivant le vivant a réponse à tout et ce
sont les bactéries qui sont susceptibles
de prendre le soufre des sulfures émis
par les fumeurs et de les mélanger avec
le gaz carbonique de l'eau de mer et
d'en faire des sucres c'est à dire de la
nourriture pour les autres et on a
trouvé aussi des molécules capables de
travailler l'adn en toutes circonstances
ce qui a donné naissance à la génomique
et c'est à la suite de sa queue une tout
un pan de la recherche médicale s'est
inspiré de ce que nous avions trouvé
dans les grands fonds le vivant a
réponse à tout mais il reste encore des
parts de mystère la terre peut ça
soupire le magma se calmer les cheminées
se bouche et la vie disparaît ou alors
la terre peut aussi brutalement se
réveiller et recouvrir de lave tous et
écosystèmes fossilise ans intégralement
tous y vivent
dans les deux cas la vie est éphémère et
pourtant la durée de vie de ces
écosystèmes est de l'ordre de la
décennie plus de vie après ça mais
quelques semaines ou quelques mois
parfois à côté ou plus loin du mois ray
apparaît et subrepticement lentement
revient la vie dès que le fluide / j
mais d'où vient-elle cette vie on ignore
encore en grande partie mais ce qui est
certain c'est que dans ces grands fonds
il existe des processus pouvant donner
naissance à des écosystèmes foisonnant
et à cet égard
c'est vrai que je ne vois pas pourquoi
on ne pourrait pas imaginer que la vie
puisse se trouver sur d'autres planètes
comme mars vénus par exemple alors
aujourd'hui que sait-on de l'océan
on connaît bien les 700 premiers mètres
des fonds marins 5% des habitants entre
10 et 20% ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'océan est encore en
grande partie inconnue et que nous avons
encore beaucoup à faire
alors aujourd'hui on peut faire une
thèse sur l'océan sans jamais navigué
on a au laboratoire toutes les données
on peut les traiter et modéliser obtenir
de nouveaux résultats sans jamais voir
la mer je pense qu'il faut faire
attention car ça risque de distendre le
lien que nous avons la réalité et je
pense que pour comprendre le monde
il faut avoir l'expérience charnelle de
ce monde
le goût de l'eau salée par exemple sur
la pole
le bruit des vagues ou même le sentiment
du corps sur un bateau qui tangue
nous venons de la mer nous l'avons
oublié alors tous les jours on entend
que le changement climatique va altérer
le fonctionnement de l'océan va aussi
mettre en danger les espèces marines
c'est vrai c'est absolument vrai et
d'ailleurs les individus dont je vous ai
parlé vivent dans des conditions
extrêmes chaude plein de gaz carbonique
et de sulfure toxiques et ces conditions
sont justement celles vers lesquels nous
tendons aujourd'hui aux et température
et
du gaz carbonique de l'atmosphère
acidité et perte d'oxygène des océans
c'est vrai mais ces individus l'un d'eux
nous indique aussi autre chose c'est la
capacité fantastique du vivant à pouvoir
trouver des conditions particulières
pour coloniser des milieu inhospitalier
inferno ça veut dire que s'adapter c'est
possible la recherche scientifique
s'adresse à l'inconnu qu elle n a
décrypté l'inconnu et son partenaire et
le rapport de ces deux là c'est un peu
comme le désire
le chercheur m
tester des hypothèses faire des
conjectures mais la découverte c'est
autre chose et découvertes
c'est rare est ce que plonger sur ces
dorsale m'a révélé au fond c c'est une
passion celle de l'exploration voilà
pourquoi je pense qu'aujourd'hui ils ne
font pas attendre de voir comment tout
ça va évaluer non il faut aujourd'hui
aller voir sur place ou en l océan
je pense que pour comprendre le monde
nous aurons aussi besoin de voir ce
monde et regarder ce qu'il ya derrière
moi cette image de l'eau de mer
ça grouille individus c'est plein
d'inconnues et si vous grossissez
l'image est toujours aussi peuplée et ça
vous donne une idée de la complexité et
du du monde et du commun que nous avons
dans le monde le sait en marguerite
duras 10
des années 2000 tout sera bouché tout
sera investi il restera la mer quand
même des océans
il faut vous alliez voir bonsoir
[Applaudissements]